Sam starts off this hour in Indiana hi
Sam how are you
better than I deserve what's up so my
wife and I we just had a baby here a few
months ago our first one and after
sitting down and looking at on moment
and that those near so some I've gotten
fairly nervous about you know where my
financial standing is and I guess my
question is how do I make a budget and
then be able to make myself and my wife
you know make ourself stick to it okay
it's a good question the great news
about having a baby in congratulations
is it makes you get serious about stuff
like that and starting to get you get
your act together on some things that's
very cool I'm glad I'm glad y'all are
doing that okay so number one when you
do a budget it is um it is not a
straitjacket it is you telling you what
to do okay okay so it's a guardrail it's
don't run off the road and so you you
the two of you sit down and say for
groceries this month we want to spend X
by the way as a side note whatever you
think you're spending on groceries are
spending more so the first month go
ahead and beef that one up okay but okay
we're gonna spend X on entertainment
okay I'll just make up another 50 bucks
okay we're just gonna put $50 in the
entertainment category and then what you
do you know the two of you are in
agreement that the reason we're limiting
our entertainment spending to $50 is so
that and so that's a big deal we can get
control of our money get out of debt
create a great life for the new baby
and so the great life for the new baby
is and change your family tree is the
goal not punishment for entertainment
sure thing and so it makes it really
easy it's like when you look at it and
you know we're at $40 and to go this
movie costs another the
dollars and we don't have that we got
$10 left in the budget we can't go the
movie because we decided that it was
more important to straighten our family
out for the good of our child than it is
for us to entertain our butts off mm-hmm
and so you are limiting you and then so
you and then of course you write it out
and you keep up with it and you track it
throughout the month and ever the every
dollar budget will do that for you okay
get to get that every dollar app it's
free and you can build it in about 10
minutes
it's all it takes okay and you'll be
able to you know that both of you will
have it on your phone and you can look
at it and keep up with it and you know
just go we don't have that so the answer
is you know you have to everyone has a
limit on everything a budget is just
admitting it mmm because no one has
infinite money right and so you know you
just say okay at this point we're not
gonna spend any more because we believe
in a bigger goal a more noble goal than
simply buying more crap at the grocery
store all right or I need this shirt
that's on sale or whatever it is right
and so right but then the interesting
thing is the things you do spend on
you've given yourself permission to do
that so you don't feel weird or guilty
about it right so like my daughter
Rachel Cruz who teaches Ramsey
personality teaches on budgeting all the
time says a budget is permission to
spend okay because you said we're gonna
spend this much on clothes and so as
long as you don't go over that amount
then you know you feel like you're a
hero and you bought clothes instead of
like okay what do you spend there to
store men you know it's like ands but
we're on the same page we're working
together so you need a good why you got
it good why it was born the other day
you have a wonderful wife right and you
need to be on the same page with your
spouse and a game plan and then have
your have your guard rails laid out and
then stick to them so very good start
very good start honor to have you in our
audience